I love being here. I love being a guy. I know we always,
you know how girls are like girl power nowadays and like that and how they do
that thing. That's how much I love being a guy, guy power, you know,
like I love being a guy. Here's why dude,
all weekend we roasted my opener because he's five, nine.
And he's trying to say he's five 10 and a half, bro. First of all,
who says, and a half, if you're tall, you don't do that.
So he says he's five, 10 and a half. That's how you know, he's really five,
nine. You're a shrimp boat dude. And it's fine.
It's fine. It's fine. He's five nine, but it's fine. And you,
and he gets so mad and we were laughing.
We were laughing so hard telling him how he was five, nine and. And he was like,
bro, bro, I'm not five nine. If I find that the Craig's five,
eight and Joe's five, seven. And I'm like, I guess so bro. And it was like,
how tall is Brad Williams? And I was like, he's 42.
Then he's two, four, uh, he's a, uh,
little person or whatever you call it. I don't know how tall Brad Williams is,
but whatever dude, my opener is five nine and Mark and I are always four, four.
Um, my opener and I are, uh, my opener Mark and I are for our far,
far nine feet tall.
So he's so he's five nine.
And we were busting them on it and he was getting so mad, but we were laughing,
dude. We were laughing. I love that as guys girls can't do that.
If a girl was like, whatever, you're short, you're ugly. You're fat and ugly.
You can't be friends with that cheque. You'd be like,
Oh that girl's done being my friend. But guys,
that means you're a friend.
[Inaudible].
Bro. You're fat. You think I don't look at my friends' faces and say, bro,
you fat. What's up with your face. You're ugly. That's it dude.
That's it. That's the best we cry laughing.
That's what it's like being a guy all weekend. He was like, all right,
so that's the theme. So I'm five, nine. He's short though. It's all good.
It kills him. He wants to be a a athletes so bad.
He tweeted the other day. So dorky,
look at this here. I'm going to look it up.
[Inaudible].
He looked, he, he tweeted the other day when we landed,
here we go. Look at this NBA dude. He loves basketball.
And he was like looking at the and he was like, Oh dreads,
going to Brooklyn or whatever the.
And he kept checking and refreshing his pain page. And he tweeted this bro, my
opener tweeted this NBA finals next four years,
colon Lakers over Milwaukee Lakers over Brooklyn Lakers over Brooklyn Lakers
over Brooklyn. And I wrote back LOL,
what a dork do more years.
And he was like, dude, that's not torquey. And I was like,
how is it not dorky to predict who's going to win the NBA
championships in the next four years, dude. That's exactly like being like,
you know, you know, you know, this is my all right, so this is my prediction.
Uh, basically, uh, the next move,
the next Marvel movies in the Marvel universe that don't exist already. Okay.
So they're going to absolutely. First of all, it just makes me laugh.
How gambit doesn't have its own, uh, origin story, which is ridiculous.
They never really explored the gambit character.
And I think that in the new year, probably 2001, 2021, 2022,
the old we'll probably explore camp at character.
If the Marvel universe is still exploding the way it is, um,
it has the chance of actually, um, you know,
taking a dip because it, they are absolutely are over branding,
but I would like to see Nightcrawler in his own thing.
I'd like to see Jubilee in his own thing. And I predict also a gambit.
Maybe I have his own origin story coming up. Um,
if they can find a very cool French French character,
because you know that gambit is a French character.
If they can find a fringe character actor, I would like to see, um, uh,
Alan Cummings maybe play him. I know he's not French, but he could,
I could see him doing that. Like that's what you're doing.
You dork predicting.
Who's gonna win the championship on Twitter,
not just in conversation and be like, Oh, I can see yada yada on Twitter.
And you're just a comedian.
And you say Lakers over Brooklyn in 2000 and 22,
you're basically a kid.
You're basically an adult living with your parents in the basement.
That's a chart, it's a chart. It's all good, sweetheart.
You're basically saying, well, I mean, you know, I would love to see, um,
basically, uh, I don't know why, uh,
I can't think of another. They have made,
so Marvel has made so many movies with all the characters that came in.
I would love to see, um, w what's his name? Who's the cyborg.
I'd love to see cyborg have his own origin story.
That's basically what you're doing. That's basically what you're doing.
Okay.
So if you like sports, that's all good. But if you tweet about predictions,
the whole thing, I just can't believe. I know I'm in the minority here.
I know sports is huge, but I just can't believe that guys for real do that.
There'll be like on ESPN, ESPN talking about how,
who they think will win the, uh, Oh, you know, it looks good.
It looks good. If it looks good. Good, good
looks good. It looks good. I, you know, it looks good. You know,
we thought that Kevin Duran, wasn't going to be around next year. And we,
you know, he probably won't be around next year,
but perhaps the Brooklyn for giving them a shot,
they get to rehabilitate him a little bit, get them to go,
come back stronger than ever. You know, I don't know, Frank, you know,
I'm not sure because you've been through this killing terrible. A lot of people,
of course, Colby had it. There's always that guy there's always got,
it sounds like this, you.
Know, the guys that like, he's good with the blue collar guys, you know,
you got to have the guys that know stuff,
but there's also this guy who's just a regular person.
And he's going to be telling you basically how it is from the ground up.
You know, you guys know when you're high towers,
basically all your money in Hollywood, what's going on,
but I know what's going on. If I'm down here, uh, Dan, and I can tell you,
LeBron, I don't know. I love,
I don't know if a Tombo could do it yet. He's tall, but he's a leg.
You son of a, you know, put them in a set of five.
But if he's outside the three front line, you know,
it's going to cause me a point of view.
I'm not sure if he can make [inaudible] MBA. You know,
Anyway, I gotta go back to the dock. He load these. I hope my analysis was,
was pure.
Thank you.
Talking to a dock worker just to get views from a dock workers I
live.
But this is my prediction is NBA finals the next four years, right?
This is what I think was just going to happen in the Marvel universe and index
for years. All right.
So what I think is possibly cyborg could have his own origin story and that's
just coming from a lowly dark worker.
But my buddy who also work in cement concrete,
they think that maybe Jubilee mice should make an appearance.
And what are the next few X-Men movies?
And then could possibly have an origin story. Or interestingly enough,
the DC universe could do a movie with an old Batman.
I see what maybe a John ham in the next few years,
or possibly even a black guy, um, you know, I could see you to,
but doing it, you know, because all the whole thing going on with,
with everything we did to try to make everybody equal, I could see that coming.
That's just coming from a lowly doc worker.
But my buddy that works at construction, he also thinks the same thing.
I would say thing. So you. We, I flew in towers in your Marvel universe,
but that's what we think.
Thanks a lot.